now we begin this hour with a look at
former pro athletes trying to change the
conversation around cannabis 19 states
have legalized recreational cannabis use
and also almost 40 states have cleared
it for medical use yet it still carries
a stigma pro football hall of fame wide
receiver calvin johnson and former
offensive lineman rob sims are trying to
change that they were teammates of mine
with mines with the detroit lions they
launched their own cannabis brand to
help educate and promote wellness we met
the two at their facility their michigan
cultivation facility and a conversation
about ongoing stigma and where they see
the industry in the future
do you believe that
athletes not just in the nfl but across
all professional sports
do you believe that they smoke
100 absolutely
calvin johnson understands that football
changed his life
[Applause]
but the 36 year old nfl hall of famer
says cannabis helped change how he now
lives his life to the nfl college
football in all major sports including
the olympics
it's also time we recognize the
potential of vital medicines plant
medicines to aid and improve the mental
health and quality of life for so many
some of the best players in the world
i'm not gonna name your names but some
of the best players in the world that's
a fact that's a fact i mean listen at
one point you're the best in the world
it's not even a question
all i gotta say is you're the best in
the business yeah right right but trying
to keep quiet stay political about this
you were a cannabis user yes and you
weren't a pothead i don't think anybody
in the world would describe calvin
johnson as that when somebody's like
well when i think of weed usage i think
of this person we need two
big pieces man
that right there i think that's what
continues the taboo and the stigma these
images that have been burned into our
minds of what a user of cannabis looks
it's hard to rehab from that it's hard
to rehab from that all right so these
are the babies these are the babies at
this cannabis growth facility one hour
outside of detroit retired nfl stars
calvin johnson and rob sims are trying
to help erase the stigma of cannabis use
we harvest them in about 63 days or so
six to three days yeah we harvest them
and then we go into our dry room and
then from there it's probably another 10
or so
days rotate that to the right primitive
their cannabis company is in the early
stages of their partnership with harvard
university to help study the causes and
effects of the traumatic brain injury
known as cte and help those suffering
from chronic pain so as we were sitting
in the locker room back in detroit would
you have thought
that you guys would be the leaders
of a cannabis brand i wasn't thinking
about cannabis when i was in the locker
room it was not even on the horizon they
don't know the healing powers of the
plant both johnson and sims view
cannabis as a healing agent and they see
their company and its product as a
potential alternative to opioid pain
medications which have been abused in
the u.s for years
according to figures released by the cdc
last year drug overdose deaths topped
100 000 for the first time in american
history and more than three quarters of
those overdose deaths were from opioids
cannabis is not only a potential
treatment for chronic pain it's a very
effective treatment for chronic pain
that millions of people are currently
employing harvard medical school
instructor and physician at
massachusetts general hospital dr peter
grinspoon more and more studies are
coming in
a lot of them just hadn't been funded by
the us government because of the war on
drugs they only studied harms and not
benefits there are millions of people
that are using it for chronic pain and
they're reporting an improved quality of
life over opiates i remember having
doctors prescribe me like vicodin i
remember the direction saying you know
take when you have pain but here i am a
football player
it was torn my pack and i just thought
it wasn't good for me
to sit at home
and pop hills i initially started uh
using cannabis in college but really
didn't become a frequent user until i
got into the nfl when the injuries
started to pile up and that was really
what it was for i mean it helped to
sleep but really just to overall improve
my quality of life i had to be there for
whether my family my teammates you know
and the weight that we have to carry you
know and to be able to compartmentalize
you know it was something that helped me
you know be able to de-stress i'm
curious to see if you can recall
the injuries you have had in your career
we've all had concussions we played this
play this great sport you know both
shoulders no surgeries there just
injured shoulders obviously fingers you
know ugly fingers surgeries um knee just
one surgery there but sprains in both
the knees ankles sprains all the way
down contusions you know just the
normal life of a football player the nfl
seems to be listening earlier this year
the league donated half a million
dollars to uc san diego center for
medicinal cannabis research to study
whether the plant can be used to help
athletes manage pain johnson and sims
both believe their product will help
improve lives that came out really yeah
that's probably the best i've ever seen
us do that right now why do you believe
cannabis can be a great form of healing
for me personally
i've dealt with opioids and for me just
the sense of balance is just off i try
to stay away from anything synthetic
they drive for about 10 days or so you
know and cannabis is a natural substance
when it comes to the nba nfl nhl major
league baseball
across all the sports really there have
been a lot of athletes coming out being
very honest about their cannabis use
why do you believe that is
you know i just think it's a it's a it's
a new day right cannabis has become
legal in these different you know states
and it's progressing to the rest of the
country
the conversation has begun to change and
it's become more acceptable i think all
athletes see it as an avenue for an
alternative healing other than opioids
most of america's top sports leagues
have relaxed their cannabis restrictions
the nfl still tests but you won't be
suspended only fine the nba has extended
its policy of not randomly testing in
season for cannabis major league
baseball removed cannabis from its
banned substance list several former
players and athletes they are have been
operating in this space including ex-nfl
running back ricky williams retired nba
players al harrington and john sally i
think the key here is that you know like
a number of other mood-altering uh
drugs that are out there including
alcohol i think there's a time and a
space and a place and for these guys
what they're saying is you know what
this is in the realm of our healing
process right and and and keeping it in
that realm i think for a lot of people
is is something that they they feel hey
i can deal with it when i look at it
from that aspect so you know i have
tourette's right i've been public about
that and i just tried cannabis for the
first time how was it a couple of months
ago um i'm still trying to find an
amount that works okay but i didn't try
it until now
because of the stigma right yeah so i
think the story is important i
felt like i shouldn't do it or i
shouldn't
maybe not admit that i'm doing it i did
it in a state where it's legal
california um but with my tourette's i
was trying to find something that maybe
just kind of just softened me a bit yeah
i like quieted me just a bit the the key
words are alternative method um you know
i i can be honest and tell you i've had
close to 10 surgeries and procedures
because of football and every time it
was pain medication that was handed to
me and i remember there was a moment in
my career where after i ran out and i
didn't need it my body craved it and i
thought i need to do something different
and all the while calvin johnson my
teammate he was saying hey i don't want
to give my body something that's going
to damage me from the inside out that's
right and then create a dependency when
i'm done playing bingo and that's why he
got into this space and i think he's
creating the education yeah it's
important an important space yeah thanks
for the story